good morning John Oh cup this morning at
about 3:00 a.m. without the ability to
move here's the story behind that I've
been having a really sort of silly
nightmare about ghosts what I'm having
nightmares sometimes I can make myself
wake up and sometimes I can make myself
realize that it's a dream and then do
stuff in the dream to be like that's not
real obviously that's what I had done I
just undid this button because I felt
like I was too stuffy they call that
lucid dreaming when you're in a dream
but you are loose and it's also and
sometimes when you wake up from the
lucid dream your body has been like
physically in the dream state and so you
don't realize that you're still inside
of your body which is weird so you can't
move and also you don't know where your
body is that you've lost the sense of
proprioception it lasts a few seconds
and then you realize where your body is
and you can move around again no weakly
for a while I don't know what that's
about anyway no amount of sleep
paralysis is make me want to stop lucid
dreaming though and to be ferreted by
thirteen-year-olds up I understand the
motivation the first time I had a lucid
dream
true story I spent the rest of the dream
grabbing boobs just walking around
grabbing a girl's boobs of 13 hello to
all have that unfortunate insight into
my profoundly heterosexual psyche let's
move on so yeah I can dream lucidly but
then when I wake up I can't move and if
you would like to leave in the comments
what devastating diseases I should be
worrying about having because of this
that that would be great so then I went
to sleep again and then I woke up at a
normal time and then we went to take on
Friday Harbor in San Juan I'll ask
Catherine when I should do my video
about today and without even thinking
about it apparently she said the
improbability of place that's my girl
and it is it's very strange that this
place exists I suppose we could say that
for all places it's like when dr.
Manhattan realizes the genetically
improbable miracle of Laurie Jupiter San
Juan Islands are kind of like that the
volcano that erupted the glaciers that
scoured the mineral deposits that
brought industry to the islands the
water that rose up to meet the coastline
the petty diplomatic squabbles that made
that land Canada this land America and
the evolutionary mysteries that led
seven to go out to sea and then come
back to the rivers to spawn us drawing
resident pods of orcas heed on salmon 25
per day the oldest Orca
among them over a hundred years old
having eaten 800,000 salmon in her life
and the fishing village seamlessly
converted into an all-encompassing
tourist destination with spas and hotels
and fancy little shops how did the world
conspire to make this place the answer
of course is that the world didn't
conspire to make this place it's always
been clear to me that Laurie Jupiter is
not objectively a miracle it's
miraculous is the love between her and
the remnant of Jon Osterman that still
exists inside of dr. Manhattan and not
going to make any sense
none of this if you haven't read
Watchmen would you know miracle of
creation is only miraculous because of
how we fit into it how we mold ourselves
into it how we become a part of it how
it fits over us like skin what makes
this place a miracle is the relationship
that we have with it and that's what
makes each one of us so wonderful to the
relationships that we have with our
world with with the land with the
animals with each other with ourselves
not because of the infinite
improbability of it although it is all
infinitely improbable because we can't
imagine anything cooler we can't imagine
loving anything more dr. Manhattan could
imagine all of the other probabilities
but he couldn't imagine any Laurie
Jupiter that he would love more than the
one that he had that's what love is
people Catherine I love you John I'll
see you on Monday